und wir gehen weiter zu Hannes rawik der
am Brocken ist und wir wissen alle aus
eigener Erfahrung auch das ist am
Brocken immer sehr windig ist das ist
heute gar kein Vergleich und da sehen
wir ihn auch schon ähm Hannes du stehst
schon mitten im Auge des Sturms hat man
das Gefühl kannst uns überhaupt noch
hören wie ist die Lage gerade bei dir
ich kann euch hören Benny Müller der
Kameramann ist mit allen Wassern
gewaschen der muss hier nicht nur vor
der Kamera stehen sondern sorgt dafür
dass die Technik einwandfrei
funktioniert das ist wirklich
fantastisch ich stehe hier im Sturm und
der Sturm ist stärker als ich jemals auf
dem Brocken vorher erlebt habe es ist
unfassbar es ist genauso wie die
Wettervorhersagen eben vorangekündigt
haben es ist ich kann mich kaum halten
hier oben wir haben von einem
ortskundigen vorhin die Geschichte
gehört dass heute tatsächlich trotz
aller Warnungen noch eine junge Familie
mit Kinderwagen und Hund ist versucht
hat auf den Brocken heraufzukommen die
ist auch noch geschafft haben mit
ungefähr zwei dreifacher Länge des Weges
der derzeit diese gebraucht haben hier
oben ist alles zu es gibt hier keine
Gastronomie es ist alles verrammelt und
die mussten dann völlig nass und und vom
Wind eben ausgekühlt den Weg wieder nach
unten antreten und verantwortlich wir
können wirklich nur sagen es ist kein
Ort für Wanderungen schon gar nicht mit
Kindern schon gar nicht für ungeübte
Leute aber der Mann von der von dem
naturschutzhäuschen hier unten der hat
gesagt es sind nicht nur die Flachländer
sondern das sind eben auch extrem
Sportler die sich bei solchen Witterung
versuchen mit der Naturgewalten zu
messen die sich dann selber überschätzen
und in Not geraten es ist wirklich nur
Minuten weiß ich ja auszuhalten vor der
Kamera mit Spezialkleidung und es ist
wirklich Wahnsinn was hier oben gerade
an Wind ankommt es ist eben 1140 m hoch
ungebremster Sturm der in dieser Gruppe
hier ausgesetzt ist bleiben sie fern von
oben von hier oben ja dann wollen wir
dich auch nicht allzu wieder aufhalten
vielleicht noch ganz kurze Frage du
warst ja auch unten wie ist die
Situation in den etwas tieferen Lagen
sind die Leute da auch in Gefahr oder
ist die Situation dort halbwegs sicher
also die Situation unterhalb des Gipfels
in den Tälern ist unvergleichlich nicht
zu vergleichen mit dem Sturm mit den
orkanspitzen hier oben aber auch unten
in den Tälern vom Harz droht Gefahr
durch herabfallendes Holz die
Fichtenwälder sind ja in erschüttern im
Zustand die Dürre Sommer haben die Bäume
getötet der Borkenkäfer hat die Bäume zu
toten geritten werden lassen die also
dem Wind völlig ungeschützt um ohne
Widerstandskraft ausgeliefert sind die
Kippen einfach um und wenn die
Wurzelballen in dem nassen Boden mit
umkippen dann knackt das Holz eben nicht
einmal sondern dann stürzt der Baum
einfach neben einem um ohne dass man
gewarnt wird deshalb Braten alle von der
Naturschutzbehörde bis zur Bergwacht bis
zur Feuerwehr heute nicht ins Freie zu
gehen keine Wanderung zu machen auch
keine Besorgung mehr zu machen gucken
sie in der Vorratskammer gucken sie in
den Kühlschrank was sie noch haben zu
Hause und bleiben Sie einfach zu Hause
verlassen Sie nicht Ihre Wohnung
vielen Dank Hannes für diese ersten
Eindrücke vom Brocken live uns
zugeschaltet hier nach Berlin wir haben
in Sicherheit erstmal und unglaublich
dass diese diese Familie da wirklich
noch aufschlägt und denkt da einen
schönen Ausflug zu machen